[Música]
es que hoy es el día internacional de la
lucha por la eliminación de la violencia
machista al margen de esta fecha la
cepal reportó que cuatro mil mujeres
fueron asesinadas en américa latina' en
el año 2020 según la onu el 30% de las
mujeres de la región han sufrido
violencia física o sexual por parte de
sus parejas y el 11 por ciento a manos
de otras personas las tasas más altas de
la región se registran en honduras
república dominicana y también el
salvador pues eso es lo que pasa ahora
con estas mujeres abusadas
lamentablemente hoy cuando se celebra el
día se conmemora mejor el día contra la
violencia machista vamos ahora a darle
paso a maría noel baeza directora
regional para las américas y el caribe
de la onu mujeres gracias maría por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 le pregunta entonces por este
crudo balance que pasa en nuestra región
en américa latina y el caribe respecto a
la violencia contra las mujeres
muy buenos días y muchas gracias por
invitarme bueno lo que pasa es que la
violencia contra las mujeres sigue
siendo un tema importantísimo pero que
lamentablemente no recibe una urgente
consideración por eso este año nuestra
campaña que comienza hoy el día de la
eliminación del avión el día
internacional de la eliminación de la
visión de género y termina el 10 de
diciembre que es el día de los derechos
humanos en estos 16 días queremos poner
el acento en poner fin a la violencia
contra las mujeres ya le pusimos un
contexto temporal porque no es posible
que siga aumentando la pandemia nos dio
un aumento de la violencia y por qué
porque las mujeres estaban encerradas
con sus propios depredadores porque no
tenían acceso a los servicios esenciales
y porque también no nos olvidemos que la
carga de trabajo no remunerados ha sido
tremenda por el cuidado la mayoría de
los enfermos han estado al cuidado en el
hogar de las mujeres por eso queremos
poner el acento
un ambiente temporal tenemos que ponerle
fin tenemos como sociedad porque esto no
es un tema de gobierno o del poder
judicial o
legislativo es un problema de toda la
sociedad tiene que cambiar la visión que
los hombres tóxicos están teniendo
contra las mujeres tenemos como sociedad
que hablar de este tema aunque incomode
y tenemos que decidir como sociedad es
ponerlo en fin nuestra región sigue
siendo la región más violenta contra las
mujeres en el mundo lamentablemente es
así y la violencia es un continuo desde
que la mujer nace hasta que la mujer
muere se da en el hogar en los espacios
públicos
el acoso callejero el acoso en el
transporte público el acoso laboral
etcétera por eso tenemos que hablar es
un tema que incomoda soler es un tema
que hay que hablarlo para solucionar
mariah cómo le podemos poner fin a este
tema tan bajo tan cobarde tan débil
bueno primero hay que hablar lo segundo
hay que tener números hay que tener
estadísticas para que la gente se dé
cuenta por eso son tan importantes las
estadísticas y los números tercero
tenemos que defender estrategias y
programas que sean inclusivos los
gobiernos tienen que ponerle plata a
este tema es fundamental que haya
presupuesto para prevenir la violencia
hay que poner el acento en la prevención
y la prevención va de la mano con la
educación obviamente
los hombres depredadores no nacen
depredadores ellos mismos quizás han
sufrido violencia ellos mismos a su vez
quizás han estado en hogares violentos
por eso tenemos que romper esos círculos
de violencia y también tenemos que
promover liderazgos de mujeres y niñas
de toda su diversidad porque fíjate que
mujeres indígenas y mujeres
afrodescendientes en nuestra región y
mujeres con discapacidad sufren mayor
violencia de las mujeres que no lo son
las mujeres somos diversas y por lo
tanto y las mujeres con identidades y
orientaciones soles distintas también
sufren más violencia entonces poniendo
en el número es poniéndole canas a estos
temas es que vamos a poder solucionarlos
nosotros dieron los mujeres el gobierno
de mexico el gobierno de francia y
muchísimos gobiernos del mundo hemos
lanzado el foro generación igualdad y
dentro del foro generación de igualdad
hay una acción para la posición
justamente para eliminar la violencia
cuya vicepresidenta de esta colección en
la vicepresidenta del uruguay está
luchando muchísimo para sacar nuevas
leyes y nuevas políticas para demostrar
que sí se puede hacer las cosas
distintas si podemos eliminar la
violencia de género si lo ponemos como
un objetivo pero tiene que ser un
objetivo del que ponga el acento en la
prevención y por supuesto en la
protección de la mujer es ampliar esos
servicios estatales y ahí también hay un
tema muy importante es un tema económico
porque las pérdidas económicas por
violencia son enormes pueden llegar a
ser mayores de lo que es estamos como
producto bruto en educación estamos
hablando quizás de 5% del producto bruto
que se pierde por la victimización y por
la violencia contra las mujeres por eso
tenemos que abordar este tema maría le
quería preguntar que genera por qué se
genera ese comportamiento en los hombres
usted hablaba de la crianza del seno del
seno familiar como entonces educar a
nuestros jóvenes a nuestros niños para
que no se repitan estos comportamientos
primero que nada las mujeres somos
sujetos de derechos humanos son los
seres humanos el problema de los hombres
violentos es que nos consideran un
objeto y como objeto nos patean nos
pegan nos discriminan y ese es el
problema nos consideran inferiores no
nos consideran un objeto un objeto
sexual por eso la publicidad que pone a
la mujer como objeto sexual no es
posible por eso estamos luchando para
que se cambien los patrones de conducta
los sesgos discriminatorios los sesgos
de que la mujer no puede que la mujer es
débil eso no es así la mujer puede la
mujer es un agente de cambio
transformador maravilloso y si en el 50%
de la población los países no pueden
interesar los países van a salir mucho
más aceleradamente de esta crisis
terrible que nos deja la pandemia del
covent 19 siempre y cuando la mujer se
ponga al centro de esa recuperación y
sea sujeto de derechos humanos eso es lo
que tenemos que tratar en una educación
a todos los hombres que nos respeten que
se den cuenta que somos iguales en
materia de sujeto de derechos humanos
de aquí a 5 años rápidamente como el
panorama un poco mejor
yo lo veo un poco mejor estamos haciendo
un programa gracias a la generosidad de
la unión europea en varios países de
américa latina que se llama spotlight y
ya tenemos un 22 por ciento más de
depredadores que han que están en la
justicia
habiendo impunidad las mujeres no
denuncian y las mujeres se quedan con
los depredadores cuando la justicia
existe es cuando se resuelven los
problemas la justicia el estado de
derecho es fundamental también es
fundamental darle a la mujer autonomía
económica porque muchas de las mujeres
se quedan con sus depredadores claro
porque justamente no tienen salidas
económico y entonces es fundamental
apoyar a las mujeres a que tengan
créditos a que sean emprendedoras a que
salgan adelante por eso la autonomía
autonomía económica el empoderamiento
económico de las mujeres es una solución
fundamental para la salida de la
violencia y por supuesto a la educación
prevención educación y por último cuando
tenemos esos problemas cautelares que en
muchos países se han contado venidas
cautelares muy exitosas